all right
there's
just no easy way to say this so
this is just gonna get this raw video
and we're gonna go with this so
unfortunately we are going to have to
continue
the game engine series
i know this might come as somewhat of
like a shock to you guys but
it it is in fact not dead and
i don't think it's ever going to die
which
is a good thing for some people
not so much for others so yeah game
engine series is continuing i know we
haven't had an episode in a very long
time uh and there is actually some truth
to the title because
for those of you who didn't tune into my
live stream on monday uh there is some
very important news regarding the game
engine series and that is the fact that
it is no longer going to be continuing
on this current channel so on my main
channel
no more game engine series due to a
number of reasons that i actually
discuss in
like the first kind of return episode of
the game engine series but basically
this is this is all you need to know
the game engine series is moving to a
different channel
this different channel is going to exist
for
more long-form
chill
kind of less well produced less edited
cherno content so basically what i'm
doing is reserving this main channel for
like higher quality content that is like
well edited usually like thought out you
know stuff like the z plus plus series
the ray tracing series other maybe
educational videos i mean stuff that i
kind of deem high quality but the
duration of the videos is also really
important the problem with the game
engine series was it was like targeting
a very very niche audience because we're
like over 100 episodes in and also it's
getting to the point where like the
amount of work that we actually need to
do like it's time to kind of just sit
down and actually physically do the work
and because of that the videos are going
to expand to be like about an hour long
maybe an hour and a half long and that
kind of like ultra long content doesn't
really fit into this channel where i try
to keep the videos like around 20 to 30
minutes you know to please the youtube
algorithm and all that stuff so there's
like it just doesn't work the game
engineer just no longer fits onto this
channel but again like
for you that shouldn't really matter too
much you just need to make sure that you
are subscribed to this new channel which
is called chono unplugged why is it
called channel unplugged because it's
going to be just kind of chill long form
content it's not going to be uh
extremely like well produced and edited
and all of that is just going to be a
kind of relaxed chill unplugged if you
will environment the game engine series
is not going to be the only thing on
that channel i expect that if i have
just general programming videos where i
just want to sit down hit record not
really worry about making sure that i'm
concise with my explanations but just
kind of go for it
those kinds of videos are also going to
go up on that channel rather than the
main channel and then as i mentioned the
main channel is going to be like
reserved for like the more kind of
popular uh you know less long kind of
content yeah that's that's pretty much
it i could go on but i don't think
there's any point too so channel
unplugged new channel in the description
below the first episode of this kind of
new game engine series is already up
there and i'm going to be live streaming
the game engine series every monday
night australian time um i'll put it on
my like twitch.tv uh stream schedule but
basically it will be live streamed every
monday and then those videos will be put
up onto that channel unplugged channel
so if you are interested in the game
manager series then you're going to have
to subscribe to that channel following
those videos possibly follow along with
live streams as well if they are at an
appropriate time for you but otherwise
yeah that's just that's that's my little
update video so enjoy the rest of your
day i will see you next time goodbye